je n'étais nulle part à ma place trop
iranienne pour les États-Unis trop
américaine pour l'Iran le seul moyen de
survivre é de ne plus F à aucun système
jolie prise de position culturelle j'ai
problème d'idtité curelle mais
norm je com tu
peuxreussionsationcère champion JEC plus
tard de
laper comment tu vas clair mieux que toi
chaque famille il est temp de te
débarrasser de toute cette colère ouais
bah j' sais donc tout n'est pas de la
faute de ma mère moi j'y crois mais
c'est plus simple d'accuser nos mères
parle sa propre langue on dit au revoir
en person RAF chaud RAF chaud tout le
monde
ch nous étions vraiment des Américains
moyens faites-moi
[Musique]
confiance